[Music]
so the widow has finally released on
Amazon Prime it stars Kate Beckinsale
who is a widow looking for her dead
husband thinking he may still be alive
now when I saw the trailer for the show
I thought it looked really really good I
got that vibe that this would be a game
changer this might be something that can
show off Kate Beckinsale's acting skills
and can be thrilling and here's the
thing I feel like this is a classic type
of show that you feel it's about to go
to the next level at any moment and get
crazy do something that's game-changing
and it never really does the good of
that is it never gets too ridiculous you
never roll your eyes at it it's I roll
free like there's nothing bad about this
show but there's nothing great about
this show it's very safe which I can
find it's a pointing because again in
this game of TV where there's so much
content right now to stand out you got
to bring that a-game and I think this
wanted to stay at B and not mess
anything out which is fine but it's
disappointing because there was so much
potential here the acting was consistent
all around there wasn't one bad actor on
this show there was no weak links the
show looks great it takes place in the
Congo it's a beauty to look at great
production design wasn't crazy about the
costume design I mean Kate Beckinsale
looks like she's wearing the same outfit
every single day every single scene and
the same ponytail they got to switch
that up a bit and make her a little
dirty or two out in the jungle kind of
fell in that trap of way too much makeup
on that type of character to save face
you can see this show has tons of
inspiration from the game Tomb Raider
Laura Croft taking place in the jungle
strong female she talks just like her
she really would have been the perfect
Laura Croft the Kate Beckinsale that's
what I was singing the whole time
watching this and as inspiration from
lost you even instead of having Sawyer
the con man here you had the con woman
who fooled Judith by taking money from
her you had a flight crash and he kind
of had this faith storyline and
redemption arc like John Locke you did
with Ariel's character here so you can
see where the writers kind of got some
ideas
from and that's not a bad thing those
are good things to look up to the thing
that was a key disappointment to me was
this was more actually of a scavenger
hunt show and her character George is
running around looking for clues to
where her husband is trying to find him
having a different powell along the way
in certain scenes but there wasn't
enough action and when there was action
it was really good and it was in a
clever way for example I loved when she
killed Peter bellow because he was
turning around the corner on that roof
and she turns around and gets him
because she hears his phone rings that
was cool and refreshing take on
something like that but I wanted more of
it I mean the trailer made it seem
action-packed and that really wasn't the
case kind of teased you a bit again
feeling a little too safe I wouldn't
mind here to have her go on a rampage in
some scenes and just go full-out because
I kind of just kept teasing that and
just never really happened I really
loved the little girl in this the
actress was great who played a diva
her story was very interesting she
actually opened the show and she becomes
Kate Beckinsale's new daughter in the
end which worked out great that theme of
this Widow losing her child and then in
the end a girl who doesn't have a mother
anymore
having a new mother in someone who lost
a kid really worked and wasn't cheesy
they connected those two stories well I
really appreciated that and that was
probably the biggest heart of this show
and it worked
I was so terrifying that finale though
thinking that Georgia was gonna leave
the girl there at that home I was like
come on she's not gonna just not take
her home with her I would have been so
mad but what was really strange about
this show was honestly the side stories
were more interesting to me than the
main plotline of her finding her husband
which is very generic and you've seen a
hundred times over the really good
episodes are actually Ariel's episode
and we learn about him and going on a
date with another blind person and how
he lied to her well sort of lied to her
and there's all drama there and his
acting was great and then also the
character of Judith gray when we learned
about her lover in the past and now she
got conned and it was a good reason for
her to kind of go nuts and get like bad
that worked well - it almost
felt like it was setting up for a show
that would be a couple seasons and it's
not it's a limited series so if I kind
of felt weird they did that but those
episodes really were to me the best ones
I wish they had actually given Georgia
some more weight to her character like
they did in those specific episodes she
has a little bit but being the lead that
she should have had more I would have
even liked to see a backstory about her
in the military just a little bit more
meat and now I feel like I attached to
Ariel I learned more about Judith and
then I was just gone that's it so there
is like a weird thing there where you
you build up a character and make such a
good episode about them and then that's
just it and there's a lot of twists here
in turns but they're very predictable I
mean you could see from a mile away when
they had mentioned that the husband was
having an affair that this guy isn't
this good guy he thought he was and they
revealed him being in on this whole
laundering money for iPhone materials
it's like you could see some hallway
same with Judith being bad we first meet
her she's very protective of her not
looking into this too much and defensive
so the reveals are I was just guessing
choice after choice it was a little too
easy now the villain who was the general
was awesome the actor Babs elusive
mockin played this so psychotically and
convincingly he's definitely an actor to
watch was actually in a black Museum
episode of Black Mirror and he was great
in that I loved how they wrote his
character and him seeing ghosts of the
people he killed and then the final
scene was brilliant with him seeing all
the ghosts of the people he killed
leading him to kill himself that was
some really powerful stuff and it also
showed he did have some humanity in
there that he did feel guilty wasn't a
total monster but as predictable as a
show was I was happy we got really all
the answers we were looking for it was
satisfying I didn't feel gypped and I
was really happy she didn't end up back
with her husband I'm happy that she
ended up hating the guy because in that
scene when she first were united it got
I got nervous said she was gonna take
him back and she seemed like she was
happy to see him it was like know him
Peter and Judith were bad people do not
get that confused because sometimes they
kind of trick you at the end making you
think one of them's maybe not so bad
that you could understand where Jews
coming from or that Peters actually
friends will and take
care of them but they all killed so many
people I mean they were responsible for
that plane crash and Peter was training
kids as soldiers come on now so I'm glad
they stuck to that and didn't make us
try to like one of them in the end and
this theme really worked well that
George is gonna end up with him because
worked amazing with that last shot when
she sees the dog running on its own and
martin suggests do you think that dog is
okay and she's like yeah it's okay knows
what it's doing and this really hit to
her character well where yeah she can be
alone and be fine she doesn't need a man
per se she's learned that she's learned
so much about how strong she is and it
fits with the dog too because when
they're looking for that dog earlier she
mentions how I can't stop looking for it
I need to find it like now so it's it
fits her character where she was looking
for a husband who was just stubborn
wouldn't stop but she really is that dog
I really love the scene particularly she
hands Emmanuel the car keys and it
explodes that shocked me that was
awesome
that came out of nowhere I missed a
manual though he was actually a really
good character
it's like season two exploded and I also
wish we had more of Martin played by
Tywin Lannister here Charles dance with
Kate Beckinsale because I thought their
chemistry was great and we only got them
really together a lot of my last two
episodes that maybe should have happened
earlier so my feelings just assump the
season where I really thought this
started slow the first two episodes then
it got hot in the middle especially when
we got to Ariel's backstory and Judis
backstory and even the episode where
they run into those guys with the guns
in the woods the medical team and she
kills her first person lined up with the
little girl killing her first person
that was beautiful and well done and
then I was really disappointed by
episode 7 it slowed up tremendously and
I was the most predictable one or sure
what the husband was up to that felt
like something you've seen 100 times
over but I was satisfied with the finale
I thought the finale was solid Kate
Beckinsale is a criminally underrated
actress she's also a great on-screen
Cryer as well and you can see out in
this show that was phenomenal and to me
it just made me feel like she was under
use and to be honest she wasn't in in
this as much as I would have thought she
would be I mean there's some episode
she's not in the scene for like 30
minutes which is again very odd for
limited seer
to have your main character disappear
for that much which could also
contribute a wire character could use a
little more weight and felt a little
empty so I'm actually gonna give this
show an eight point three it went up the
more I thought about it it really had
some nice moments again I appreciate
nothing was viral feeling it was good
wasn't bad but I just was disappointed
it could have been so much more
especially with a good cast they had
it's not a game changer like I thought
it would be you've seen this all before
but it's still solid it's worth the
watch but if you agree with me I would
tell people to walk to watch it don't
run to see it put on your list but don't
put at the top let me know what you
thought of it down below I love to hear
your thoughts on this series anything
you have to say would be much
appreciated I read every comment and try
to respond as many as I can please
follow me at Steve rd1 on Twitter and
Instagram for more of me and please make
sure to subscribe I review bunch of TV
shows you don't want to miss one of
those and I'll see you next time